Es geht wieder los mit der Ligatour zu den europäischen Top-Ligen bei den Männern und gleich mit einer Neuerung. Heute haben wir mit dabei nicht nur die Serie A, nicht nur La Liga, sondern auch die Ehre die Vigie. Ich freue mich sehr auf Christian Bernhardt, Fabian Pakulat und Daniel Zander jetzt hier im Rasenfunk.
Und nun im Programm der Rasenfunk.
Ich hab drauf gewartet, wir haben drauf gewartet. Jetzt ist es endlich soweit. Wir sprechen wieder über den europäischen Topfußball. Schön, dass ihr hier seid, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und schön, dass wir hier einen Neuzugang haben vom Team von Oranjefußball auf Twitter. Sehr empfehlenswerter Account. Kommt unbedingt mal zu Blue Sky, bitte. Daniel Zander ist hier. Hallo Daniel.
Ja, liegt es vielleicht ein bisschen an der Spielweise von Twente? Also wenn man jetzt nicht Highlights von denen suchen würde, wären das ja eher die 1.30er-Zusammenfassungen, oder?
Ja, also Twente ist jetzt nicht so bekannt, dass die Alkma imitieren mit den 1.30er. Sie sind eigentlich eher schon auf Sicherheit aus, auf Defensive. Das stimmt schon, das könnte vielleicht deshalb auch sein. Und ich glaube auch, dass wenn Sam Stein in einem Team ist, was offensiver ausgerichtet wäre, der quasi noch präsenter und noch stärker am Rampenlicht stehen würde. Und ich kann mir gut vorstellen, gerade wenn Sam Stein auch vielleicht innerhalb der Liga wechseln würde, zu einem Team, was mehr presst. Wenn ich jetzt an Eindhoven denke zum Beispiel, dann kann ich mir vorstellen, dass er noch prominenter gerückt wird. Aber so ein bisschen ist er– vielleicht tut Sven Teh ihm nicht gut, aber das wäre auch ein bisschen fies formuliert tatsächlich. Aber ich glaube, dass es ein Spieler ist, den man auf jeden Fall in zukunft auf dem Radar haben muss, der auch irgendwann seinen Weg in eine der 5 Ligen gehen wird. Davon gehe ich fest aus.
Den behalten wir im Auge. Uli hat sich alles schon notiert, um dann sein Premier League-Debüt kommentieren zu können. Dann brauchen wir noch einen Anzang Hero aus der Serie A, bitte. Christian?
Ja, da landen wir bei Davis Vazquez. Jetzt bin ich gespannt, ob Uli auch nickt. Noch nicht. Ich sehe keine Nektion. 26-jähriger kolumbianischer Torhüter, den hat Milan vor eineinhalb Jahren geholt und seitdem nur ausgeliehen. Unter anderem zu Sheffield. Der hat eine Rückrunde für Sheffield gespielt, auch ein paar Spiele gemacht. Er war dann letzte Saison an Ascoli ausgeliehen, in Serie B, und wurde jetzt diese Saison an Empoli ausgeliehen. Und Vazquez steht stellvertretend für Empoli. Denn Empoli gebe ich auch zu, für mich auch vor der Saison, einer der Abstiegskandidaten. Steht nach vier Spielen noch ungeschlagen da, sechs Punkte und hat unter anderem gegen Juve, Roma und Bologna– ist eines Zeichen Champions League Teilnehmer– gespielt. Hat in Rom gewonnen, 2-1 bei der Roma, da die Roma eben ins Loch gestürzt. Jetzt am vergangenen Wochenende 0-0 gegen Juve zuhause. Echt gut mitgehalten. Am Ende sogar noch ein, zwei Chancen auf den Sieg gehabt. Und der Herr Vazquez eben, der Kolumbianer im Tor, hat wirklich sowohl in Rom als jetzt auch gegen Juve ganz, ganz stark gehalten. Haben jetzt in vier Spielen zwei Gegentore kassiert als einer der potenziellen Abstiegskandidaten. Und dementsprechend ja sinnbildlich einer, der jetzt nicht groß auf der Liste steht, den eben die wenigsten wahrscheinlich auch kennen. Aber eben der mit Empoli wirklich, ja, das bisher sehr gut macht. Und anders als Boudinese, würde ich eben sagen, zählen dann die sechs Punkte ein bisschen mehr, wenn man sich halt eben die Gegner anschaut. Denn in Rom gegen Juve und auch, wenn Bologna jetzt sicherlich auch noch mit Problemen gestartet ist, aber es ist halt trotzdem Champions League-Teilnehmer. Und wenn du da aus Empolis Sicht ungeschlagen rausgehst, sogar sechs Punkte mitnimmst, dann ist das logisch ein großartiger Start und Vasquez hat da großen Anteil daran.
Es ist noch sehr, sehr früh, das weiß ich. Aber kann es sein, dass sich wirklich interessanter Abstiegskampf in der Serie A ankündigen?
Wahnsinnig, absolut. Also ich habe es schon, ich dachte es mir schon vor dem Start und jetzt hat sich es komplett rauskristallisiert. Also für mich ist eine Mannschaft, also wenn sich die dieses Jahr rettet, dann ist das für mich eines der größten sportlichen Geschichten der letzten Jahre. Das ist Venedig. Also bei Venedig kann ich mir im Moment nicht vorstellen, wie die sich retten sollen. Aber nach Venedig könnte ich die jetzt 5, 6 nennen, die da definitiv reinrutschen können. Empoli wird da auch immer, wird da im Spiel bleiben, auch trotz dieses Starts. Aber bin ich völlig bei dir, Max? Also der Abstiegskampf in Italien ist ja wahnsinnig schwer zu prognostizieren. Ich habe auch Monza ein bisschen auf der Rechnung. Jetzt spielen die plötzlich 1-1 gegen Inter am Wochenende und gewinnen fast. Klar, das ist alles Saisonstart, ist schon klar. Aber ich glaube, der Abstiegskampf in der Serie A wird wahnsinnig eng, wahnsinnig heiß und vielleicht der Klassiker ist immer das noch ein, zwei reinrutschen, mit denen man nicht gerechnet hat. Also, ja, da glaube ich wirklich, bis auf Venedig werden sich da sehr, sehr viele warm anziehen müssen. Oder umgekehrt, können viele vielleicht positiv überraschen.
7 von 20 Teams haben noch keinen Sieg nach vier Spieltagen. Das habe ich so auch noch nicht häufig gesehen in einer Tabelle. Wir gucken es uns genau an und wir gucken natürlich auch auf den Ansagen. Hier der La Liga. Das war jetzt falsch, also der spanischen Liga. Fabian, wen hast du uns mitgebracht?
Ich habe euch wieder einen Trainer mitgebracht und ihr werdet euch jetzt ein bisschen wundern, denn er steht im Moment am Tabellenende der Primärdivision. Es ist Valencias Trainer Ruben Maraja und er ist, glaube ich, so die ärmste Sau auf dem spanischen Trainermarkt oder in der spanischen Trainerwelt im Moment. Valencia zu trainieren macht spätestens seit Peter Lim dem Verein gehört überhaupt keinen Spaß und seit zwei Jahren noch viel weniger, auch katastrophal geführt. Die besten Spieler werden jedes Jahr verkauft. Es werden Spieler hingestellt, die der Trainer nicht möchte und Ruben Maraja hat letztes Jahr aus der Not eine Thun gemacht, hat viele junge Spieler hochgezogen, zwangsweise, weil ihm einfach Spielmaterial gefehlt hat und hat die letztes Jahr zu einem wirklich, muss ich sagen, sehr competitive, wettbewerbsfähigen Team gemacht, die letztes Jahr vielleicht sogar überperformt haben und ich glaube sogar einen einstelligen Tabellenplatz am Ende hatten. Und ich habe mir das erste Saisonspiel angesehen, Valencia FC Barcelona, auch um das Debüt von Flick zu sehen und so weiter. Und Valencia ist da in Führung gegangen mit 1 zu 1, hat wirklich, wirklich stark gespielt. Man hat halt irgendwann gemerkt, ok, es fehlt die individuelle Klasse und Barcelona hat das dann noch gedreht mit 2 zu 1. Aber das war so ein Knackpunkt für beide Trainer, so ein bisschen für Flick war das so der gelungene Auftakt für die Spieler, das Zeichen-Case passt. Bei Valencia ging es ein bisschen nach hinten los. Die haben dann die nächsten Spiele alle unglücklich verloren, würde ich sagen, bis auf das letzte Spiel, das war bei Atletico mit 3-0, da war wenig zu holen. Jetzt haben sie natürlich auch noch interne Probleme zu meistern. Hugo Duro, ihr bester Stürmer, ist verletzt. Rafa Mir, den anderen Stürmer, dem sie haben, dem wird im Moment sexuelle Aggression vorgeworfen. Er ist zwar freigesprochen, aber die Vereinsführung, die gute Vereinsführung und nette Vereinsführung, hat dem Trainer auch bemittelt, hey, der ist freigesprochen, den kannst du wieder haben. Ruben Barach hat aber gesagt, nee, ich will, dass der jetzt erst mal mindestens zwei Spiele noch pausiert. Das ist eine Disziplinlosigkeit, ganz egal, ob der Vorwurf stimmt oder nicht. Es ist im Nachtleben passiert, er hat sich nicht professionell verhalten. Das wird jetzt erst mal von mir bestraft, auch als Signal wahrscheinlich an die Mannschaft. Das macht er wirklich in keiner einfachen Lage, denn er hat im Kader keine Alternativen auf der Stürmerposition, also wenige, die ihn weiterbringen würden. Vor allen Dingen, weil er es letztes Jahr so überragend gemacht hat und weil er dieses Jahr auch wieder sich da wirklich mannhaft– mannhaft klingt bescheuert– weil er sich vor sein Team stellt und das Beste rausholt, wünsche ich ihm ganz viel Erfolg, auch für dieses Jahr wieder. Denn ich glaube, es ist fast der schwerste Platz, wo man im Moment im Spanien trainieren kann, auch wenn es ein Traditionsverein ist und auch wenn viele Möglichkeiten eigentlich da wären. Aber es ist alles andere als leichter zu arbeiten. Und er macht das bisher, finde ich, sehr, sehr gut. Und deswegen ist er für mich mein Ansatz-Hero.
Also der Downfall von Valencia beginnend mit dem Champions-League-Final-Teilnamen Anfang der 2000er um die Jahrtausendwende bis jetzt. Ach, das wäre mal so ein schönes achtstündiges Tribüngespräch. Aber mal gucken.
Wenn das neue Stadion kommt, wird alles besser.
Ja, das ist ja wie, wenn endlich der letzte Band von das Lied von Eis und Feuer rauskommt, dann ist das Ende der Lebensstoffe nicht mehr so schlecht. Aber gut. Das ist Valencia und Ruben Barraja. Sehr schön, dass du ihn hier mit reingebracht hast. Uli, du hast vorhin reingegraben, du hast schon genannt, das war dein Anzeigenhero, den du besprechen wolltest.
Nein, den habe ich, den habe ich.
Hast mir noch jemand untergejubelt.
Ja, ich würde dir noch schnell einen unterjubeln, weil dann ist auch der mit drin. Auch das mache ich durch die Hintertür, weil sein Trainer wird des Öfteren besungen, ist Manager of the Month geworden im August. Finde ich zu Recht übrigens, ich nenne mal Tony Bloom, Besitzer von Brighton, weil ganz oft wird gesagt, Besitzer und Investoren sind nur Müll. Die Chelsea-Story, dass die sich schon wieder trennen wollen und einfach nur Geld rausprüfern und so weiter. Als Beispiel auch nicht ganz korrekt, aber es gibt auch die Gegenbeispiele und Tony Bloom ist so eins, der sehr datenorientiert den Verein führt, aber sich auch wahnsinnig viel sagen lässt und ein Transferfenster hingelegt hat, das für mich der Wahnsinn ist. Daniel wird 90 Prozent derer kennen, die gekommen sind oder Leistungsträger sind gerade, also Verbrücken, Van Hecke, Feldmann. Dann haben sie Minttee geholt, ebenfalls aus Niederlanden, Mats Viver natürlich vor allen Dingen. Das ist, glaube ich, sogar der Königstransfer, auch wenn der nur einmal gespielt hat bis jetzt. Brian Guder haben sie verpflichtet, nicht Niederlande, aber in der Nähe zumindest.
Stimmt, das wäre ein Niederländer.
Stimmt, das wäre ein Niederländer auch, genau. Und den Zerbi-Abgang und die Abgänge der größeren Spieler der letzten Jahre, wie immer schon ein bis zwei Jahre vorher abgefangen und auch ansonsten, glaube ich, ein sehr guter Typ und auch einer, den man sich wahrscheinlich als Fan dieser Truppe wünscht, weil der selber nämlich schon immer Fan war von Brighton, gerne selber Profi geworden wäre. Dann hat er sich entschieden, dass er Profi-Spieler wird. Muss jeder selber wissen. Aber hat diese Gambler-Ader nicht in den Verein mitgebracht, sondern im Gegenteil, führt ihn sehr vorausschauend und hat mit Fabian Hützler, glaube ich, auch jemanden geholt, der wunderbar passt und mit dem sie die zukunft haben dürften. Das sieht bis dato echt sehr gut aus, muss ich sagen. Gestern war es wohl nicht so gut. EFL Cup habe ich nur gelesen, aber habe nichts gesehen. Da war Hützler wohl auch nicht so ganz glücklich. Aber bis dahin ist es ansonsten eine gute Saison.
Ja, da werden wir, glaube ich, immer mal wieder drauf schauen auf Brighton. Das ist ja wirklich eine erstaunliche Geschichte. Dann haben wir noch den Moment der Woche oder der letzten Wochen. Daniel, was ist da aus den Niederlanden zu berichten?
Ja, ich konnte mich entscheiden. Ich habe zwei Momente genommen.
Hast du mir etwas untergegeben? Von wem hast du dir das denn abgedeckt?
Ja, ich kann aber dem einen Untergegebenen auch direkt anschließen an Oli, denn es geht auch um Feyernoord, also der Verein, von dem er als FIFA gekommen ist für 32 Millionen. Denn die Bremmer League hat zum Besten dafür auch gesorgt, dass Feyernoord jetzt ziemlich schlecht da steht. Annes Lotz, Liverpool, Merckmann Riesig, dem neuen Trainer, den Bliske, der erst versucht hat, ein neues System zu implementieren. In 3-5-2 ist dann nach 1-2 Spieltagen schon wieder umgeschwenkt auf dem 4-3-3, weil es nicht funktioniert hat, aufgrund auch der fehlenden Wingwigs mit Luffes und Bart Newcob, die dafür nicht geeignet sind für so ein vielen Systeme in der Dreierkette. Und Feyernoord ist aktuell auf Platz 8 mit 6 Punkten aus 4 Spielen. Das ist nicht der Anspruch von Feyernoord, die auch durch Abgänge, auch Herdreuder, so Leipzig zum Beispiel, relativ spät auch im Transferfenster, jetzt vor kurzem erst Probleme hatten und haben da gleichwertig gute Leute dann auch nachzuholen tatsächlich. Und in meinem Moment sind die Momente nach den Spielen, wo es zu einem Huddle kommt. Also im Prinzip so ein Kreis von den Spielern, der bei uns normal ist. Nach dem Spiel hebt man in der Mannschaft zusammen, bespricht sich noch mal kurz, pusht sich. Und das ist in den Niederlanden nicht so üblich, zumindest nicht so regelmäßig. Und der neue Trainer, der neue Trainer Brian Priske, hat es selber etabliert, nach jedem Spiel. Und dann gibt es jetzt in der Presse, in den Niederlanden, die wildesten Diskurse und Debatten über diese Huddles, diese Mannschaftskreise. Da werden dann Psychologen zur Art gezogen, die ja nur überurteilen, ja, es ist ja eigentlich wichtig, dass man diesen Moment, deswegen habe ich es auch jetzt als Moment gewählt, den Moment nach der Nierlage oder nach dem Spiel der Mannschaft bespricht. Und nicht erst mit den Fans oder mit der Familie oder einzelnen Kollegen. Und dann gibt es dann wieder viele Tweets, die dich darüber auslasten und lustig machen. Also es gibt dann viele Debatten, auch noch absatzsportliche, über sowas zum Beispiel, die dem Trainer Priske dann auch nicht schmecken dürfen tatsächlich. Das fand ich dann auch irgendwie im passenden Moment, über den Moment nach dem Spielern zu reden.
Ja, sehr gut. Ganz kurzer Hinweis. Grüße gehen raus an Jason von den Wochenend-Rebellen. Der würde sich sehr darüber freuen, wenn mal auf den Mannschaftskreis verzichtet wird. Aber das wissen jetzt nur alle, die Wochenend-Rebellen hören oder den Film gesehen haben oder das Buch gelesen haben, die Bücher gelesen haben. So, und dann dein zweiter Moment.
Der fließt sich auch an Feyernoord an. Das ist ein langer ruter Faden, den ich jetzt hier ziehe. Denn der zweite Moment gehört Kroningen. Die sind Aufsteiger. Die sind zuletzt vor zwei Jahren dann abgestiegen unter sehr viel Lärm mit vielen Protesten der Fans, die das Stadion dann den Innenraum gestürmt haben. Es gab Spielabbrüche nach Becherwürfen und so weiter und so fort. Die sind jetzt aber da aufgestiegen direkt und haben jetzt nach fünf Spieltagen neun Punkte. Sie sind auf Platz vier und haben noch nicht verloren. Sie haben gegen Alkmaar auch in Rémy errungen und jetzt auch gegen Feyernoord. Nach 2-0 Rückstand haben sie dann in der 90. Bus 1 noch das 2-2 erzielen können. Das ganze Stadion ist im hohen Norden, der die ganze Ektase pur eskaliert. Das ist ein dauernder Moment von Roningen, die defensiv sehr gut stehen und darüber auch viele Punkte mitnehmen. Dieser Moment ist jetzt kulminiert bei diesem Ausgleichs-Tor gegen Feyernoord. Ich glaube, das haben sich auch die Vereine nach den letzten Jahren verdient.
Da werden wir, glaube ich, auch immer mal wieder noch mal draufschauen. Schöne zwei Momente. Fabian, was möchtest du uns aus La Liga noch berichten?
Ja, ich habe mich für das Tor von Jesus Navas entschieden für den FC Sevilla, der einen 1-0-Sieg für diesen Club gesichert hat. Das war der erste Saisonsieg. Sevilla ist auch alles andere als gut in die Saison gestartet und hat extreme finanzielle Probleme. Sie haben eigentlich nur ein insgesamtes Transferbudget von 2,5 Millionen Euro für das ganze Team für die ganze Saison. Transfer-
oder Gehaltbudget?
Gehaltbudget, genau. Jetzt ist es natürlich so, dass der Liga-Präsident Tewas Sevilla ein bisschen hilft und die jetzt erst mal so ein bisschen mauscheln lässt und so weiter. Man will ja nicht einen Traditionsclub gleich total abschießen und so weiter und so fort. Aber dementsprechend könnt ihr euch vorstellen, dass auch was kadermäßig Verstärkungen anbelangt, wenig passiert ist und viel verkauft worden ist. Jetzt ist es so, dass Jesus Navas eigentlich Sevilla-Legende, ehemaliger Nationalspieler, war auch bei der EM dabei, glaube ich sogar noch, dass er eigentlich gar keinen Vertrag mehr hatte beim FC Sevilla. Und die Fans dann so laut stark protestiert haben und der Spieler auch selbst gesagt hat, er hätte sich gewünscht, irgendwie schön von seinem Verein verabschiedet zu werden. Das hat eben nicht geklappt letztes Jahr und dann hat aber der Präsident dann doch noch eingelenkt und hat ihm noch mal ein Jährchen gegeben. Ja und jetzt hat er den ersten Saisonsieg erzielt und ist danach in Tränen ausgebrochen und hat danach im Interview gesagt, er ist jetzt glaube ich auch schon 7 oder 38, dass er eigentlich nur jeden zweiten Tag gehen kann im Moment. Also er trainiert einen Tag, muss einen Tag Pause machen, weil er nicht mehr kann, dann trainiert er wieder einen Tag, dann muss er wieder pausieren und er ist nach wie vor für Sevilla unwahrscheinlich wichtig und hat jetzt wie gesagt den ersten Saison-Sieg für die erzählt und ist dementsprechend ja auch sehr emotional dann eben berührt gewesen und war für mich dann– es gab mehrere Geschichten, aber das war auf jeden Fall der Moment des letzten Wochenendes.
Und bei Sevilla, also sie werden diese zweieinhalb Millionen Gehaltsbudget, wenn sie sich einhalten können, da wird es noch Punktabzüge, sonst was geben, also das wird noch ein Thema dieses Saison werden. Mich hat es ehrlich gesagt gewundert, dass das nicht schon während der Transferperiode größeres Thema war. Ich habe es zumindest erst jetzt mitbekommen, als dann auch über Barca die neuen Gehaltsobergrenzen einfach festgelegt wurden. Es hat mich ein bisschen gewundert, dass es da nicht den großen Ausverkaufsrun auf Sevilla gab.
Sie haben zumindest, wie gesagt, viele Spieler noch verkauft, haben aber trotzdem auch relativ viel geholt, auch kostenfrei und Sie müssen jetzt gucken, wie Sie das Ganze budgetieren wollen. Ich glaube, Sie haben jetzt einen Aufschub bekommen bis zur Winterpause, müssen mal gucken, was Sie an Sponsoren-Geld noch reinbekommen, was Sie sonst noch verkaufen können, um das irgendwie einigermaßen auszugleichen. Aber der Verfall ist natürlich heftig von letztes Jahr Champions League. Die Gruppenphase nicht geschafft, dadurch allein hast du ja schon ein ganz anderes Gehaltsbudget und dann sind Sie ja auch nur relativ knapp dem Abstieg entrun, letztes Jahr. Jetzt haben Sie eigentlich einen guten Trainer mit, Garcia Pimenta, der letztes Jahr bei Las Palmas sehr erfolgreich war, der aus der Barca-Schule kommt. Aber in Sevilla im Moment trainieren ist auch alles andere als eine einfache Aufgabe.
Schwieriger ist es dann nur Schatzmeister von Sevilla zu sein. Darüber werden wir glaube ich noch sprechen im weiteren Verlauf dieser Saison. Christian, über was sollen wir in der Serie A noch sprechen?
Ja, ich muss kurz noch mit dem Update starten. Also aus Rom sickert immer mehr durch. Wir haben ja dadurch, dass das erste Mittwoch passiert ist, quasi mit der Rossi. Nee, also es ist wirklich jetzt sickert so langsam durch, dass anscheinend da auf, weil Uli ja vorhin ein positives Beispiel von Ownership gebracht hat, dass womöglich die Entscheidung nach aufgrund von statistischen Basis getroffen wurde. Der Rossi hat wohl auch zum Abschied von allen Angestellten gesagt, diesmal kehre ich nicht mehr zurück. Also den haben sie jetzt komplett verloren. Also die Fritkens machen sich unfassbar angreifbar mit dieser Geschichte. Gestern vor dem Haus von Rossi haben sich noch viele Roma-Fans getroffen, um ihm Zuspruch zu geben. Also ich sage mal so, Mats Hummels hat es sich bis jetzt denken können, jetzt merkt er sehr schnell, dass Rom einer der emotionalsten Fußballstandorte in Europa ist. Also das nur so als kleines Update. Mein Moment ist, ein etwas längerer gezogener Moment, es ist Antonio Conte als Napoli. Der aktuelle Moment ist der, Napoli hat am Wochenende 4-0 auf Kaljari, auf Sardinen gewonnen in Kaljari. Und ich muss kurz die Klammer setzen, Napoli hat also vor dem Auftaktspieltag, also Antonio Conte, neuer Trainer, vor dem ersten Spieltag hat Conte auf der Pressekonferenz mal schnell klar gemacht, wie unzufrieden er damit ist, was auf dem Transfermarkt bisher passiert ist. Und dass hier gar nichts vorwärts geht. Und einen Tag später verliert Napoli 0 zu 3 bei Hellas Verona. Dementsprechend war die Laune, war die Lage. So, das war der Start. Und jetzt aber haben wir den vierten Spieltag. Und jetzt steht Napoli mit neun Punkten da. Sprich, sie haben alle anderen drei gewonnen. Stehen vor Juve, stehen vor Inter, vor allen anderen. Am Wochenende gab es einen 4-0. Ja, und die Herrschaften, die seitdem gekommen sind, funktionieren gleich. Am Wochenende lukaku-tor, Vorlage Quaratzkelia, Quaratzkelia-Tor, Vorlage lukaku, lukaku beim Debüt-Tor und Vorlage. lukaku, vielleicht zur Erinnerung, wenn es eine Verbindung zwischen Spieler und Trainer gibt in den letzten Jahren, dann würde ich lukaku und Conte da nennen. Also die zwei suchen und finden sich regelmäßig und haben auch schon ein paar Mal bewiesen, dass diese Symbiose ganz gut miteinander funktionieren kann. Also Napoli, am Ende waren es knapp um die 150 Millionen, die De Laurenti es noch ausgegeben hat. Conte hat mehr oder weniger alles bekommen, was er wollte. Neeres kam noch von Benfica, der jetzt auch dreimal von der Bank schon drei Vorlagen gebracht hat. Und jetzt wieder der Blick zu Uli und da bin ich wahnsinnig gespannt. Es sind ja auch noch die Herren McTominay und Gilmour da. Die arbeitet Conte jetzt so langsam ein im Training. Bis jetzt ist er klassisch mit seiner Dreierkette gestartet, so 3-4-2-1. Klassisch Conte, Quaratzkelia und Politana oder Neres so ein bisschen hängend hinter lukaku. Aber es heißt, was man aus Neapel hört und da freue ich mich sehr drauf. Er arbeitet eigentlich schon am 4-3-3 oder 4-3-2-1, um eben auch McTominay reinzubringen. Und ich muss sagen, da freue ich mich jetzt schon sehr. Ich glaube, dieser McTominay, ich glaube, das könnte ein Riesenfit für Napoli sein. Anguissa, Lobotka plus McTominay noch dazu. Die Torgefahr von McTominay muss ich nicht erzählen. Die erzählt euch Uli am besten. Also, ich glaube, da passiert sehr viel Richtiges. Ich habe es auch schon vor der Saison gesagt. Don't mess mit Antonio Conte, wenn er eine Mannschaft hat, die er auch gestalten kann. Und er und jetzt kommt es. Der große Spaß beginnt gerade diese Woche, während alle jetzt in den nächsten Wochen und Monaten in Italien unter der Woche quer durch Europa reisen, während Antonio Conte mit Napoli von Sonntag bis Sonntag arbeitet. Das heißt, nach dem Sonntag- oder Samstag-Spiel immer eine komplette Trainingswoche, weil sie nicht europäisch spielen. Dementsprechend wird Napoli lange dran bleiben. Ich glaube, Fabian hat ja vorhin schon mal einen Tipp abgegeben Richtung Saisonende. Ich gebe meinen auch ab. Wenn Napoli nicht in die Champions League zurückkehrt, dann weiß ich nicht, was passiert. Also Napoli und Conte werden dieses Jahr sehr gefährlich sein.
Ich gebe auch einen Tipp ab. Rasenfunk, Ligatour, September 2026. Antonio Conte ist im Sommer im Streit. Ich glaube, er ist weggegangen, weil er die Transfers nicht bekommen hat, die er wollte, obwohl er eigentlich alles bekommen hat, was er wollte.
Sehr gut möglich, aber eben in der Saison jetzt, ich bin wirklich sehr gespannt. Und gerade dieses McTominay und Gilmour auch. Bei Gilmour darf man nicht vergessen, den kennt er noch aus seiner Chelsea-Zeit. Da war er da schon wahnsinnig angetan. Den wollte er auch unbedingt. Was ich da vernommen habe, da hat Gilmour auch bei Brighton sehr viel dafür getan, dass es doch noch geklappt hat, dass er gehen konnte. Also das sind jetzt wirklich spannende Leute. Und nochmal, Conte kam Woche für Woche, von Montag bis Freitag oder von Montag bis Samstag, seine Systematik einarbeiten. Und wenn das sich dann jetzt auch noch von einer Dreierkette löst, ich glaube, das ist noch das letzte Rädchen, dann wären die richtig gefährlich. Oder sind sie ja im Prinzip ja schon. Und sorry, jetzt wirklich, allerletztes zum Absch… Ja, tut mir echt leid, aber das ist, weil es jetzt um Momente geht, da müssen sich jetzt vielleicht die Älteren da dazuschauen, die Jüngeren sagst vielleicht nichts mehr, aber Totto Schilacci ist gestern verstorben. Und ja, Totto Schilacci ist, ich weiß, die WM 1990 in Italien ist aus deutscher Sicht logischerweise für immer mit dem deutschen WM-Titel verbunden, völlig zu Recht auch, aber in Italien und ich glaube auch in vielen Ländern darüber hinaus ist die WM 1990 wirklich mit Totto Schilacci verbunden, der da mehr oder weniger aus nichts kam und ja, diese Heim-WM dann auch mit seinen Toren zu einer ganz ganz speziellen gemacht hat. Also wirklich eine spezielle Figur wurde jetzt vor einer Woche schon zum ersten Mal eingeliefert, da hieß es noch, ah, es wird wieder, aber jetzt ist er nochmal, hat sich verschlechtert und ist verstorben und wirklich Italiano Vantanto, Tosquilaci, das ist in Italien eine ganz emotionale Erinnerung.
Ist als Ersatzspieler zur WM mitgekommen, dann Torschützenkönig geworden. Ich habe mir eine sehr schöne Charakteratur gesehen, wo dieses Stäbchenmännchen, das Maskottchen der WM 90 trauernd an seinem Grab stand. Die fand ich sehr treffend. Also trifft, glaube ich, unsere Alterskohorte. Ja, ist klar. Absolut. Sehr gut, dass du es noch erwähnt hast. Hätte mich geärgert, wenn ich das vergessen hätte.
Ich hatte auch das Glück, einmal mit ihm zu sprechen, ein Interview zu führen. Und es ist wirklich eine dieser Sportfiguren, die einfach unglaublich mit einem großen Weltsportereignis verknüpft sind. Also ich glaube, da gibt es nicht so viele, die sozusagen, ja, die einfach so viel positiver Erinnerungen bei ganz, ganz vielen Menschen einfach weg.
Da finde ich auch so ein Gesicht, dass wenn du einmal gesehen hast, das vergisst du nicht mehr.
Nee, absolut.
Es gibt so Menschen, wo ich denke, boah.
Ja, definitiv. Und hat er mit Robby Baggio damals auch im Sturm zusammen gespielt und mein Baggio ist sowas wie Fußballgott in Italien und dann dieser Combo aus Baggio plus Gellace, der aus dem Nichts kam und Baggio hat jetzt auch ganz emotionale Worte gefunden zum Abschied. Baggio ist ja eigentlich einer, der nicht mehr in der Öffentlichkeit stattfindet, das sich komplett zurückzieht und gemeint, ja Toto, du hast mich auch diesmal überrascht, so auf dem Spielfeld. Also ja, wie gesagt, wirklich eine emotionale, italienische Fußballgeschichte.
Ja, danke, dass du es noch erwähnt hast. Und dann haben wir noch einen Moment aus der Premier League. Uli.
Ich möchte es nicht zu morbide machen, deswegen jubel ich da hinunter. Aber trotzdem sei das einmal erwähnt. Aston Villa ist für alle, die diesem Club anhängen, glaube ich wahnsinnig wichtig gewesen. Er hat in dieser Woche Champions League gespielt, erstmals nach 41 Jahren. Und in genau dieser Woche, in der sie spielen, nämlich am Montag, verstirbt einer aus dem Siegerteam von 82, nämlich Gary Shaw, der bis dato die meisten Tore innerhalb einer Europapokalsaison geschossen hat. Das ist manchmal so bittersüß, wenn solche Momente dann zeitlich auch so aufeinander fallen. Weil auf der einen Seite gedenkt man einen der ganz Großen in diesem Verein, in dem wahrscheinlich größten Team des ersten Villa hatte. Und auf der anderen Seite ist dann die neue Generation da, die sich das total erarbeitet haben. Auch da mit vernünftigen Besitzern, die schon Geld reinpulvern, aber einen Trainer machen lassen. Und es ist denen, glaube ich, in Birmingham wahnsinnig wichtig, dass sie endlich wieder da sind, wo sie denken, dass sie hingehören nicht, in Anführungszeichen, nur in der Conference League, sondern ganz oben in der Champions League. Aber damit wir nicht komplett traurig rausgehen aus der Sache, Most Random Transfer Ever. Das ist wirklich ein Moment, der seit zwei Tagen bei mir nachhalt. Anthony Martial ist ohne Witz zu IK Arthéen gegangen. Wir leben einfach doch im Fußballmanager. Es können Dinge passieren, die können nicht passieren. Das ist der Golden Boy von Joel Glazer, den er mit Pelé verglichen hat, als er ihn geholt hat. Er hat ihm diesen völlig irren Deal gegeben, der bis jetzt in den Sommer reinging. Jetzt haben sie die Nummern gewechselt und haben die Schlösser wahrscheinlich ausgetauscht, damit er bloß nicht mehr an den Fuß der Inkerin reinsetzt. Einfach Wahnsinn.
Das habe ich gar nicht mitbekommen. Da hast du mich jetzt blank erwischt. Ja, so ist es. Das ist Fußball. Das ist einfach Fußball. Das ist Fußball. Nicht nur der Ausgleich in der 91. Minute oder die Geräte, die zur Notbremse wird, sondern auch das ist Fußball. Das ist Business-Fußball. Ihr 4. Es hat große Freude gemacht, mit euch zu sprechen. Herzlichen Dank an Daniel Zander von Oranifußball, an Fabian Pakulat, an Christian Bernhardt und an Uli Hebel. Ich werde alles verlinken, wo man euch folgen kann. Ich werde auch noch zwei Nachrufe verlinken auf Tutu Skilaci und Gary Schorr. Dann könnt ihr, wenn ihr wollt, da auch noch weiterlesen. Herzlichen Dank euch, Fieren, dass ihr mit dabei wart bei dieser ersten Ligatour dieser Saison. Danke euch. Da müsst ihr jetzt alle sagen, danke, lieber Max. Die alten Mechanismen, die müssen noch reinkommen. Die neuen Mechanismen sind auch, dass die Hörern und Töre uns bitte weiter unterstützen. rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Da erfahrt ihr, wie das geht. Und in dieser Folge danke ich Viva La Ben, Peter, Uli Klümper, Hiro Li und Hendrik HP7. rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Und dann bewertet uns auch sehr gerne bei der Podcastplattform Eure Wahl und gebt uns Feedback auf dieses Format. Freuen wir uns auch sehr drüber. Und ansonsten bleibt gesund, bleibt dem Rasenfunk gewogen und bis bald. Macht's gut.
Ciao.
Der Rasenfunk lebt von Euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank.